foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell join this
hour by the Rachel Cruz and we are here
to take your calls America the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the number again is triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
call up we'll talk about budgeting and
debt and how to stop keeping up with the
Joneses and what's going on with this
housing market we are here for you and
Rachel today is a momentous day because
we just released a brand new episode of
our new podcast smart bunny happy hour
the glasses right there we should here
George do it well we don't have this is
what you'll hear at the end of my class
podcast this is smart money happy hour
[Music]
didn't really work but you know we tried
you know what today's episode is Rachel
uh it is Disney adults all about Disney
adult Disney trauma and how they priced
out the middle class those of you who
have been to Disney lately you know
exactly what we're talking about it's
gotten very expensive we have a
Shameless testimony from a real-life
Disney adult on our team and we pulled
her in halfway through the recording I
share my personal Disney trauma which
I've unpacked live it was almost like
live therapy Rachel thanks for being
there it was really good I'm glad I
could ask the questions to get to the
heart of the issue George for you you
dug in yeah but it's a fun podcast if
you haven't listened to it make sure you
do and subscribe because we just bring
real life things that are happening and
how it involves your money so we we've
enjoyed what's the goal I know and
people have said that it is the show the
Ramsay network has been missing wow I've
seen that a few times
that's very kind yes so thanks thanks to
producer James for leaving that review
we appreciate him now we've loved seeing
the reviews and the people just want
that casual conversation that feels like
they're hanging out with friends it's
not stuffy we're just having a good time
very authentic yep probably the most
authentic version almost too little
editing I kind of wish they'd edit out
Parts where I screwed up but hey that's
part of the entertainment love it all
right let's get to the phones Amanda
joins us up first in Charlotte North
Carolina Amanda welcome to the show
hey good afternoon how's it going
pretty great pretty great
um yeah so I just have a question
um looking for like some reassurance or
maybe not so much of reassurance uh
regarding purchasing a home next month
um my husband is a regular listener of
you guys and he's recently pulled me in
and we've become like big fans together
and I'm like well maybe maybe we just
need to reach out and get their their
input they would pay
um if we're making that decision on this
so do you feel like financially this is
unwise right now
so I think so I haven't had any doubts
or anything leading up to this until we
started listening to y'all's uh podcast
Our advice and now you're like oh no
yeah maybe maybe we should revisit this
well hit us with some numbers here
yeah so
um let me start by saying that this will
be our second home we sold our first
house it was three bags for a good
profit earlier this year in March uh
sorry around in April so we bought it in
March 2020. great interest rate for 305
and we sold it for 500 this past April
so that was a pretty good return Yes
um the reason that we decided to sell is
because we need we don't have children
yet we're in our early 20s and we needed
more space to grow into
especially since those three beds and
from our initial Health uh really turned
one was taken away to become an office
because now we've both since covid work
remotely
um so we need office space
um and then also our family they all
live like out of town so whenever they
visit it's not going to be like hey I'm
here for a few hours to get by it's
going to be an overnight type of thing
you know so we wanted a safe
presidential comfortable
um and yeah to just grow into so um you
guys have that I'm not
no we don't you know we don't we don't
have any debt and you're renting my
student loans all right yes so currently
yeah so we've been renting since we uh
sold back in April the house that we're
building should be
finished
um next month we have 225 000 in savings
um our take-home income after taxes is
about 89.30
um and we have good credit uh we also
invest
um
each week in stocks so I feel like we're
pretty like financially found right now
but uh going into the house you know we
locked in our mortgage rate mortgage
rate right now rates right now are crazy
um we when we first bought in 2020 we
had like a three percent you know first
time at home buyers yeah
uh now our mortgage rate is 5.125 I know
that we can refinance like next year you
know when the time comes but
um that rate is higher
um what's the house costs comparatively
the house cost is 615. okay and you're
gonna how much you're gonna put down of
the 225. yes well we've already put down
34 000 earlier this year and we're
planning to put down an additional 180
from savings in our monthly payment
would be total not just printable but
total would be 26.35
. and that's on a 30-year or 15.
30. okay uh well I mean you're asking us
for advice it seems like this is uh this
train has left the station
has it I'm not sure I can't back out now
I want to make sure yeah well
contractually are you able to yes what's
stressing you out Amanda Amanda we're
okay
okay what what's making you question
everything
because this is such a like a large
amount of money that we currently have
in savings and like the world is just
crazy and I just want to make sure that
this is like a good
um investment to the home or if we
should and they're like I know like the
debt
um not the debt but it's under like a
ratio you guys use for like here yes I
crunch the numbers for you it's about 30
of your take-home pay but that's not a
30 year if it was on a 15 year which is
the only mortgage we'd ever recommend it
would be much higher so it is a lot of
your take-home pay hopefully your
incomes go up you're also not on fire
this is not gonna like tank you guys
it's just gonna be hard to have margin
to do other things like invest 15 of
your income into retirement and say for
college and pay off the house early and
so so far a lot of your discussion has
been emotionally charged and there's not
enough room but we don't have kids yet
but when we do and the parents are
coming they can't get a hotel we got out
it's just been a lot of just emotional
instead of logical so that's my biggest
pushback is not you didn't need a house
it was just a reason you've jumped into
this
sure yeah that's that's fair yeah yeah
so
well and Amanda where you guys are at we
had a call yesterday that
um similar thing they were building
interest rate got too crazy now they
can't afford the house I mean it's like
this whole thing so
uh yeah the numbers are kind of tight I
mean for you guys for what we would
normally say yeah this is a smart move
you're a little bit above that I would
still keep three to I would put six
months in your emergency funds out of
that 225 keep six months uh aside just
to give you some more peace of mind
hopefully your incomes will come up to
meet this but but also Amanda like at
the end of the day yes your home is a
huge financial investment it's a huge
purchase uh but if you guys get a year
into this and you're like God we gotta
get out
you can always sell it I mean like it's
not ideal but you're not attached to
everything in life and so maybe it's
even got Equity since you guys have been
building uh but yeah your reasonings why
to do it
but hey you can enjoy it that's true
well you know it's not the house is not
on fire and it's not done being built
yet so keep saving and try to pay this
long thing off as quickly as possible
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz
this hour this is the Ramsay show give
us a call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five well I feel like right
now is the time of year when it's make
or break when it comes to our goals we
had a reset when school started again
but we're headed into a holiday season
and let's be real it gets hard to stay
motivated and we all have goals whether
it's to find a better job make more
money pay off some debt build stronger
relationships and it can be hard to keep
that momentum going but here's the good
news coming up in a couple of weeks we
have one of our biggest events smart
conference we're headed to Dallas Texas
for a day-long jam-packed event where
you're going to get advice from leading
experts on money personal growth career
mental health and your marriage you're
going to leave with all the knowledge
and motivation you need to reach your
goals and live the life you want people
come from all over the country to join
us for this event so join me and the
rest of the Ramsay personalities Dave
Ramsey Dr John deloney Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis Rachel Cruz and get a
plan for your money your relationships
your career and yourself your personal
growth so join us live in person October
22nd get your passes before they sell
out at ramseysolutions.com
events Cody joins us up next in Atlanta
Georgia Cody welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you how are you guys doing doing
great how can we help
hey I'm trying to find out whether or
not I need to pretty much sell my car
um I played the credit card game pretty
stupidly uh racked up you know good
chunk
um has paid it all off have about eight
thousand dollars in cash less add
another in total return in my life seven
thousand dollars in student loans and
combined we make about 80. uh and we
just had a uh a kid about four months
ago congrats and we oh thank you thank
you we owe about 25
000 on a brand new 2022.
wow what car is it
uh Chevy Equinox okay
and how what's your total debt all I
heard was the student loans in there
um nothing
we don't own a house the car is our only
debt oh the car is the only guy okay you
had mentioned student loans but I guess
you said you paid that off
no we have 7 000 in student loans we
paid off all the credit cards okay
that's just a quick definition of debt
owing anything to anyone for any reason
is there any other debt you want to tell
us about I think he said it I think he
said seven thousand in student loans
yeah but then I said is that it is it's
just the car sticking up for you Cody
okay Cody I'm just trying to get my
ducks in a row here so we got 7 000
student loans 25 000 on the car and
you're wondering if you should sell the
car to get out of all this debt
feel like I'm asking a stupid question
no there's no stupid questions no you're
not I want to get my details straight so
we can help you yeah so what's the car
worth
pretty much the loan trade in value
on the loan is what it's worth now okay
so it's equal it's worth 25 you owe 25.
correct it would be a wash for me
um and I'm just wondering especially in
today's market expect you since we have
besides the student loans we have no
other debt but we also want to save up
for a house so it's kind of okay what
they do you know and especially we've
even thought about selling a car and not
having a car we both work from home
we're like if there's an emergency call
9-1-1
so this is your only car
yes oh yeah no we need a car I would
yeah I'm a car up there with like a at
least one at least one now you have 8
000 in the bank you said right
said the question correct so for me Cody
the rule of thumb always is if you can't
pay off your car in 18 to 24 months you
need to sell it do you think you guys
can pay off 20 25 000 in debt and in a
year to year and a half
we probably could
but we want to do it sooner okay so
that's my question so you could keep the
car yeah and you guys could pay it off
you know total two years would be the
the most but maybe if you could do it in
a year year and a half but if you don't
want to go through the pain of all of
that yeah you have an asset right there
that you can trade in take some of the
savings you guys would get a a beat or
it would not be a great car but you're
talking about selling the car anyway so
I don't think you're too concerned with
it uh and then and then throw some money
at the student loan get that paid off
then then save back up to pay for a car
so all of that would be the route you
would go versus just decreasing your
lifestyle dramatically
um to pay it off but you're going to be
decreasing your lifestyle anyways Cody
to uh to get some money to you know get
that beater and to pay off your student
loans and then to save up for another
car if you want to replace the beater so
yeah so to recap Cody what would we do
today if you decide I'm going to sell
this car sell the car for 25 the loan's
gone now take maybe 7 000 of the 8 000
you have in the bank go get yourself a
reliable used car and then you're a baby
step two paying off those seven thousand
student loans and you can do that much
more quickly right we're talking a few
months
correct yeah so it speeds up the process
by a year and a half yep
which I think excites you more at this
point which is great
yeah well especially because we don't
have a ton in retirement or 401K which
I'll you know yep for in almost our 30s
kind of scares us a little well you got
time man you guys are still young you
got this so I think you know what to do
anytime someone's willing to sell the
car I know I'm like all right that's a
hard emotional place to get to and if it
speeds up the journey because the
Journey's tough two years of really
sacrificing versus for a car yeah a car
is an is a reversible decision in some
points because you know you can just get
rid of it I can't sell my student loans
you can sell the piece of paper and get
money back so that is the nice thing
about that but uh we're wishing you the
best Cody Mike joins us up next in
Hartford Connecticut Mike welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey thank you for having me sure how can
we help today
uh so basically um I'm in a little bit
of a different situation than I usually
hear on here but
um I'm 28 years old I I make uh plenty
of uh money I save probably 40 plus
percent of my income every month wow
um but what I'm trying to figure out is
when can I stop working I mean even if I
had to get a part-time job or whatever
when is do I have enough to retire I
mean I do the math and it's like I won't
be I I'll be like 50 I'll be 55 before I
can actually walk away
well it depends on your lifestyle of
course and so it just depends on how
much do you need to live on per year and
then we can back that out and say how
much do we need to have in our nest egg
in order to withdraw that much per year
and not run out
so do you have those numbers I could
probably have everything paid off and I
could probably comfortably live on say
60 000 a year
60. I could probably have everything
paid off in the next like 10 years or so
house and everything do you have any
other debt
I have a house I have a car and those
are my two pieces of the debt okay well
one thing is our plan teaches to do 15
of your income into retirement once you
have all your debt paid off in your
emergency fund and it sounds like right
now you're going all in on investing
yeah yeah instead of the day
like other than maybe my 401k you're
saying instead of investing at all pay
off that house as quickly as possible
exactly
up to 15 Mike so we would say even pause
everything pay off the car all your
Consumer Debt needs to be gone save up
some cash on the side which you've done
uh for about three to six months of
expenses and then save 15 of your income
into retirement and then there's like
the you know the whole fire movement
George about you know retiring early and
all of that
um and so yeah retirement it we always
say it's a number it's not an age and so
you may get to a point Mike that you're
like man I'm gonna
yeah keep investing 40 of my income or
something you know after my house is
paid off you want to pay off the house
and then maybe you go crazy and invest a
ton and you can retire early depending
on if the numbers work out um I just
know from age 28 to age 58 your standard
of living is probably going to look
different so you probably have 60 in
your head but between now and then
life's probably going to happen maybe
you'll get married maybe you have kids
you gotta pay for college I mean stuff
just happens and so the whole fire
movement of that whole you know
um retiring early is a it's cool because
it's like hey let's just like save a ton
not live a lot of our on our lifestyle
so that we can
quit work and we can enjoy life and all
that so there there's a great motivators
for that and I think it's a really cool
idea I also just think that things
change so much during that time
um so I just wouldn't I wouldn't rush
into it but I would have from how you're
talking Mike I feel like you would be
able to retire early but running the
numbers to know what you're going to
live off of but no knowing that that's
probably that intentionality of 28 we'll
get you there and we have a great
calculator go to ramseysolutions.com
click on free tools check out our
retirement calculator you can plug in
all your numbers and figure out exactly
when you can have that dream retirement
it may look like 1.5 million and so now
we can reverse engineer it all right how
soon can we get there in that Nest Egg
but it all involves getting out of debt
and staying out of debt thanks for the
call Mike appreciate it this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined today by Rachel Cruz we are
co-hosts of the Ramsey show but also
co-hosts of the newest show on the
Ramsay Network smart money happy hour be
sure to check that out wherever you
listen to podcasts it's a fun casual
conversation about money pop culture
entertainment there's a lot of laughter
a lot of stories that you would never
hear on a show like this
this is a family show here on the Ramsay
show things go off the rails in smart
money happy hour it's a good time it is
fun so check that out so Rachel we hear
a lot uh in social media about this
passive income yes the kids have heard
about this buzzword they're clamoring
for this passive income where you just
wake up and money shows up in your bank
account and it's just it sounds great
really does sound wonderful but we know
that passive income especially when it
comes to real estate because that's one
of the most touted uh some of the most
touted advice on social media is the
best passive income is real estate and
you know we love real estate around here
when done the right way yeah not this
nothing down real estate and just get
whoever you can in the door and start
collecting checks it's never that simple
nope and our friend Graham Stefan who
has been on the show recently one of the
biggest personal finance YouTubers out
there he's big into real estate that's
how he made his millions he's super
young guy uh maybe a year or two younger
than us and he posted a video on his
YouTube channel titled my tenant just
trashed my house and we've got a video
of what the inside of that house looks
like so if you're watching on YouTube
you can peruse that but we'll give you
the play-by-play it's not pretty it
looks like a like a college dorm room oh
look at that just crap everywhere
kitchen's destroyed he's walking through
pointing everything out and so these
people just moved out is that what the I
I hope to God they don't live there
anymore I'm guessing they were evicted
all of that stuff in the closet oh it
looks like a hoarder yeah if they like
moved out and then they left all of this
in the rental and they're like see ya so
gross what happened James is agreeing oh
man this this is a lot of work the dark
reality of passive income everywhere
stuff all in every cabinet and every
door oh
you know what's extra sad this was a
long-term tenant of his 10 years he
never raised the rent because they were
such a good tenant up until they
apparently weren't well until they left
slash didn't because they left all their
crap behind
the nightmare just continues just stuff
everywhere I mean the amount of clean
he's gonna need a cleanup crew just to
deal with this mess yes well you take
the security deposit if you ever got one
10 years ago for sure that will start to
cover it keep that so the advice around
real estate investing ours sounds insane
and it's pay cash for your investment
properties because you're not factoring
in Risk yeah and the hope is I'm gonna
put nothing down and I'm gonna charge
them more rent than the mortgage is
worth I'm gonna take the spread and I'm
gonna make five thousand dollars a year
ten thousand dollars a year right that's
usually the margins when people call
into the show
after all of their expenses yeah you're
not making a full-time income from one
property that's all right so yeah so
starting off small
and you know obviously this Market looks
a whole lot different
um and it's hard to get a good deal but
always mostly the for me buying real
estate when you go in to invest into it
the money's made at the sale like you
like when you buy a property that's
where the equity should be you should be
able to get a deal so it's such a good
deal pay market rate no you already have
automatic Equity
um yeah and start small and again I know
this was in a different world but even
for for Winston uh and myself my husband
and I when we we bought a condo it was
in short sale in Nashville over in
Nippers Corner area if you know where
that is the um Old Hickory Boulevard and
uh I don't know but you know some people
know and yeah we bought it in short sale
and I mean it was a few tens of
thousands of dollars back then it wasn't
a lot and it was kind of not it was
nasty so we had to go in and kind of fix
it up and we've rented it and kept it
for about eight years and got so much
equity and ended up selling it to help
pay for the house that we built and it
was it was it was a great
um it was a great experience
mostly because we paid cash we got a
deal on sale we didn't go big right it
was just a condo uh but it was in a
growing part of Nashville it wasn't
really in a hot area but it was in a
growing area and then we were able to
use that asset later for our primary
residence when we wanted to build and
helped use that to fund it so so all
that to say it can be done well if you
start small it doesn't have to be big in
Grands and right now it's probably not
the market to find a great deal there
might be some foreclosures and short
sales coming up but as of now like it's
it's probably not a great uh it's not a
great Market to get a great deal yeah
and a lot of people are looking into
what's called house hacking which is not
really a hack you just buy a house and
then someone else lives there too yeah
and they help cover the mortgage so not
it's not a New Concept and you've seen a
lot of people want to buy duplexes and
triplexes and live in one living one and
rent the others out but guess what
you're not the first one to think of
that and so they're actually in really
high demand which means people are going
to be will willing to pay more than you
are to get that property which means
you're not getting a deal so it's always
it sounds better in theory and on paper
than it is in reality and you're not
thinking about well what if the HVAC
goes out and also I have an HVAC 2 I've
got to worry about so yeah you better
have that house has to have its own
emergency fund to cover those repairs
and you better have good landlord
insurance to cover more than just the
property there's a lot of risk involved
that that can help cover and on top of
that
you you can't guarantee there's going to
be a renter no and you can't guarantee
they're going to pay and take care of
your property and we saw this with covid
there's a moratorium on evictions yep so
you could just not pay your rent and the
landlord can't do anything about it yes
so yeah there's you know again we love
real estate when it comes to investing I
think it's a really smart thing I think
when you're to the point that you're
diversifying more than just
um retirement accounts uh I think it's
great I mean I because it goes up in
value it's a it's a great it is a great
investment but it's just uh you want to
move a whole lot smaller slower 10 times
slower than what the culture is saying
right now the culture is like get in
it's not a big deal and then if you have
your primary mortgage and now this
mortgage and then someone doesn't pay
and then the HOA comes in I mean it's
just it can be a disaster and it's a
part-time job I mean if you have tenants
like you're at their beck and call if
something happens as a landlord and so
you just have to know all of that going
in so it's a lot of work and a lot of
dedication it's worth it if you do it
the right way
but that's the problem is it seems like
everyone's fast tracking it and it's and
you're you're adding risk when you go
into debt for it and even paying a cut
to a property management company it's
still not passive there's still work to
be done there's still a lot of
communication back and forth and you've
got to keep your eye on these properties
I've got family friends that didn't do
their due diligence when screening
tenants and they didn't have a bank
account and they stopped paying rent and
then they can't evict them and then
they've set up drug rooms in there you
just don't know what these tenants are
doing it's a true story Rachel that's
all I can disclose at this time no but
uh Graham's video is about 10 minutes
long but we just wanted to play you his
quick takeaway at the end of this
horrific situation let's see that clip I
gotta say even with a management company
owning a rental property is not truly
passive income and it requires a
consistent amount of work if you're
expected to be successful at it
there you go that sums it up in the
nutshell that sums it up thank you so
much Graham and uh congrats on all the
success he's had in the real estate
world yeah with your current house
though I want that even when you think
you're a great tenant and we want to
believe the best of people you know as
landlords tenants out there I mean we we
tell you people Everyone listening like
rent if you yeah if you have debt and
all that so like it's I think renting is
great and there are great tenants out
there but no one treats it as well as
you are they do it you know it's not
their it's not their house for sure they
don't live there like a rental car you
know when we travel more car you just
can I don't know rental cars Rachel just
throw rappers in the background you just
drive it like you wouldn't drive your
home and your minivan has no goldfish on
the floor if you keep that thing clean
[ __ ] and span wow [ __ ] and span well
there you go if you want to get into
real estate by the way this is this is
the time and place to do it you've got
to be completely debt free
home and everything and then save up
cash and buy it that investment property
and I know that's you're like George
that's a 10-year it may be a 10-year
Journey but guess what your risk is so
minimal comparatively to having a giant
mortgage and you've got to make that
payment every month that mortgage lender
whether or not your tenant pays you or
not so that's a scary situation to be in
so do this wisely
and don't just blindly follow some guy
on Tick Tock who's doing the Burr method
and we're just gonna buy with nothing
down and then we're going to refinance
it do the cash out and put that on the
next one it sounds so fancy and in
reality it's how a lot of people go
broke and stay broke
so don't do this stuff do it the slow
way be a crock pot in a world full of
microwaves because it only takes one
extra second and that in that microwave
Rachel for that popcorn to burn and
everything's not gonna burn no no no no
mine's good to go never know don't do it
crock pot it Rachel did this this week
with chili turned out great didn't it so
good there you go America this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast joined by
Rachel Cruz host of The Rachel Cruz show
and we are both co-hosts of this show
and smart money happy hour and we're
excited to take your calls Triple eight
eight two five five two two five Valerie
joins us up next in San Antonio Valerie
welcome to the show
hi you hey how can we help today
hey I just have a kind of I'm hoping to
quick question
um me and my husband have about six
student loans
um and when we did an IDR repayment it
gave us a zero payment
um because of our family size to our
income
and so even this was before the um
you know forbearance so I'm just
wondering we have them in order from
lowest to largest but we also have a car
payment Beyond those and since if we're
paying on them we're not gaining any
traction I'm just wondering do we still
keep that going even though we're not
gaining any momentum excuse me because
there's no minimum payment
well the problem with these programs is
that they are not a blessing
just because it's zero dollars doesn't
mean that that interest isn't causing
that to balloon and so I would if I'm
you I'm getting out of this program so
that I can put as much on these loans as
I can
can you get out okay
uh yeah we can and um and it's not a
problem to do that I just wanted to make
sure that that was the right thing to do
per se
yeah honestly from what I've found
looking into this you're talking about
income based for payment programs for
those listening and it sounds great in
theory because it's based on your income
but the problem is you're not even
touching the principle
you're just scraping by trying to get
the interest and what happens is that
sixty thousand dollar loan becomes an
eighty thousand dollar loan and now
we're going how is it how am I going to
ever get out of this thing how much do
you guys make Valerie
um uh it's like right over a hundred
okay and you have six student loans
total you said
right yes man at the time that we had
done the IDR we weren't making that but
like our family size grew and also our
income has grown which has been a
blessing but we haven't really made any
progress on the student loans since then
and we've been paying everything else
off and so now when we're at the point
to start the student loans those are the
next in the snowball
um but I didn't know since it you know
shows our payment is zero do we still go
ahead and attack that first
yeah I would I would say what George
said I would go ahead and just get out
of that program so that you're making
minimum payments on everything and
you're at least staying currents
and you're not letting yeah you're
paying on the principal and uh you're
not letting you know this interest just
absolutely accrue like you're you're
staying up to date with them
and then that way when you get to each
one you've been paying all along which
is going to help the does that snowball
go that much faster
okay great that's what I needed to know
thank you so much for your help I really
appreciate it yeah absolutely thank you
thanks Valerie oh yeah that income based
repayment that it really grinds my gears
Rachel well I'm sorry but it sounds good
I mean like you know the idea behind it
I guess is good but then it ends up yeah
with people and it's like you're not
even touching the interest you're and
some of them are in touching the
principle if she if you're doing you
know what her example was and it's like
oh man it's gonna be so much more in the
end if you're in that get out as soon as
you can and attack this debt it's not
going anywhere and it's only going to
grow and it's going to become more you
know unmanageable and it's going to be
scarier and scarier as that thing grows
Amy joins us up next in Atlanta Amy
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call I just have
a question really quick I currently work
for a private tech company I have stock
options that are fully vested but not
exercised and they're worth about a
hundred thousand pre-tax the company is
currently in the process of creating an
internal marketplace where the employees
can buy and sell stock but I'm
considering a job change
so I'm not sure what I should do with my
stock if I leave the company
what do you want to do do you have an
angle you're going I'd like to do this
well I'm thinking about selling all of
it because I don't know I won't be
plugged into the company so I won't know
the help of the business if I leave uh
and if they go under then I lose all of
that money but I also don't know if they
take off and go public I might be losing
out online there's always no what if and
I used to when I was like 18 I worked at
the Apple Store and so I got the
Employee Stock purchase program and so I
had some Apple stocks and I sold a bunch
to help my debt free journey and now
looking back you're like what if I held
on to those in 15 years later it would
have been that you know so there's
always the what ifs but I think about
what's gonna set me free tomorrow and
set me up down the road and hanging on
to these I don't think is going to do
that for you so even if you weren't
leaving the company I would tell you to
sell any vested stocks are you getting a
discount is this an employee
stock purchase program situation yes yes
a deep discount so you take that
discount and then you sell it and you
make your profit and you go invest that
in something a lot less volatile to
where you're not going to lose sleep as
you watch the company go up and down and
up and down yeah it's just putting all
your eggs in one basket type mentality
Amy versus we just love diversification
and so there's less risk because your
money is spread around and with company
stock it is so easy just to go one track
but then what's what's scary obviously
is like the ultimate right Enron or
something happens and it's like oh my
gosh all that so there there's just not
a lot of risk when you just do kind of
you know a boring mutual fund I'd say
boring but it's the truth it may not be
as exciting
um but yeah I I would dissolve the
stocks if I were you do you have any
financial goals do you have debt you
want to pay off
oh my goodness student loans student
loans for days how many students what's
the number what's the number on the
student loan
125. is that all of your debt
uh no um my other debt's minimal my
truck's like ten thousand dollars and
yeah I don't have much and I don't have
credit card debt it's just the student
loan so think about going from 135 down
to 35 tomorrow now obviously you've got
to set aside money for taxes so it's
going to be you know you're going to
have more uh than that in loans but
that's going to set you up an incredible
way to get rid of all this debt
it's 800 a month for my student loan
payment so that would be really nice to
get rid of that oh my gosh absolutely
for sure well I would see this as a gift
Amy I mean it's awesome I can help jump
start the stuff
exactly and don't look like I'm thinking
I just wanted to make sure yes don't
look back with a regret regardless of
what this company does and if it goes
public and it goes zoom zoom you just go
good for them and I'm debt free and I'm
happy too there you go Matthew joins us
up next in Las Vegas Matthew welcome to
the show
thank you so much sir appreciate it how
are you guys we're doing great how can
we help today
so um I am 31 years old I've been at my
place of work for most of my adult life
since I was 21.
um it's a I work in healthcare out here
in Las Vegas
um I was recently offered a opportunity
to pretty much almost double my income
a little bit of backstory is I mean why
I've stayed at this company that I'm at
for so long it's 10 to 15 minutes away
I'm comfortable this new opportunity
would be almost
I want to say 45 minutes away
um it is at a
a place that kind of cares about their
employees more than where I'm at right
now my biggest concern is I'm just
I'm I'm afraid to make the jump because
I've been I've been at this place so
long and so
um I I kind of feel like you know uh if
you want to use an analogy like a lion
that
the cage door is wide open but he's too
afraid to walk out that cage door to see
what's on the other side just because
I've been at this place so long yeah so
I um I'm calling you guys I'm trying to
get um trying to get advice
um I just had my first interview today
um they made it seem
um that
um they're going to press forward in the
hiring process
um I should also add that I am newly
married my wife is very excited about
this
um but again it is you know a big
commute a new a new hospital setting and
so I guess I'm just afraid yeah and
Matthew let me validate that that
feeling though because any time we
change anything in our lives anything
and especially a job change which is a
big change that affects your entire day
it's going to feel scary Matthew like it
is because we are just when we're
comfortable in something it's
predictable we know what's going to
happen and so that fear is very real and
very valid now do we let that be the
motivator for how we make decisions no
and this 45-minute commute Hey listen to
a few podcasts you're not going two
hours away 45 minutes double your income
it's a great work environment better
than the one currently Matthew do it do
it today do it you get the job take it
and guess what you can always move
closer to work and you're gonna make
mistakes Matthew and that's okay too
okay learning curve it's okay but don't
don't let that fear dictate your
decision making that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we have a
conversation about your life and your
money so give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Rachel
Cruz we are taking your calls if you
need some confirmation affirmation
motivation we can help out with all of
those things there's a lot going on in
the world a lot going on in your life
and we just want to have an honest
conversation and be that third party and
give you some advice Debbie is kicking
us off in Orlando Debbie welcome to the
show
thank you for having me happy to have
you how can we help today
well we've been touring with the idea of
selling our house I think we missed our
opportunity a few months ago when
everybody was buying out houses but
um but we've been talking about it even
before
um everybody else was talking about it
because our house is too big for us
we're just the two of us now my husband
and I and we have a 3 500 square foot
home with six bedrooms it's just the two
of us so we wanted to sell the house but
for another reason is the traffic is
ungodly here in Orlando and the other
reason is I have no children or
grandchildren anywhere near me none of
them are in the state of Florida why
would they do that to you Debbie why
would they do that to you they took all
your grandkids
I love jobs everywhere that they all are
grumpy people
yeah you're giving us some logical
reasons here to sell so what's the
holdup
well
um the problem is that I don't think we
can afford to move because we only pay
1500 a month for this house
because of the mortgage
what's the mortgage what's left on it
225 and what's the house worth
10.
okay so you're going to get out of this
thing with plenty of equity
yeah but I can't even find a 300 000 two
bedroom two bath house but where are you
where are you wanting to move Debbie are
you wanting to stay in Orlando or just
down and just downsize
well my husband wants to stay in Orlando
I'd like to live closer to the kids but
he doesn't want to make a choice between
Alabama Texas and Alaska oh wow quite
the spread there we're gonna be honest
all right but but he told me if I got a
job in one of those States then we
wouldn't have to choose between one of
them so I've been putting out
applications in all three states okay
well I would say Debbie a motivation to
sell just because you guys feel like
it's it's too big isn't necessarily you
know an urgent reason to sell I
understand if the upkeep is too much and
you're like oh man but if you're running
numbers
and saying okay what else could we get
um to be able to even pay cash yeah for
something or you guys thinking even
something as small as like getting like
a town home type thing are you wanting
another
another just residence
well we even thought about a town home
for a while but my husband likes to play
Loud Music he's really into music so a
neighbor really that close might be
difficult for him party on we're always
they always wanted to I know a party at
Debbie's house dad turn the music down
yeah so if you so if you can get yeah 16
and you said you guys have looked for
houses even like in the three four
hundreds
yeah and yeah I haven't been looking for
anything really any more than 350 000
because I would like to be debt free
sure yeah how old are you guys
66 and how much do you guys make
he's already retired so he just lives on
his he just has his retirement and I'm a
nurse practitioner
so you want to keep working how much do
you make
120.
that's nice and are you do you want to
retire soon
I would love to retire but I do like
what I do so I don't think as a nurse
practitioner I'll ever truly really
retire I might end up doing some
Ministry but yeah awesome well and you
could go part-time and you go I like
doing it but not 60 hours a week you
know here you go so yeah and I'm doing
the math here and you'd have about three
70 380 maybe after fees right if you
sold this house today
but then I got to pay the realtor too
well that's what I mean after after your
fees maybe 360 after all the fees and so
then we go what can we find for 360 and
maybe it's a little further out but you
guys won't have to travel to work
anymore so location is not as much of an
issue
yeah and Debbie too definitely want to
get out of this area it takes me two
hours to get home from work oh gosh no
thank you
I know are you working with a good real
estate agent right now
we are he's I don't think he's with the
Ramsey group but he might be because he
does teach it at his bike at his church
but he's a great Christian guy and we
really trust him okay we actually sold
us our house 15 years ago well I I mean
is is he looking for you right now and
going hey here's our budget we don't
want to go over 360. find us something
that's a single family home that's got
at least two bedrooms
no I that is my dilemma right there if I
sell the Realtors tell me Debbie what's
gonna what are you gonna do if you if
you sell the house I will will be
homeless because we don't have a plan
well you get the plan first and then you
can match this up I mean once you you're
under contract then we go ahead and list
yours and we know yours is going to sell
but we can start getting your house in
shape to sell as well so you don't have
to put it on the market quite yet
right but I can't afford to get
something else right now either until we
sell this house so we're in a dilemma do
you but you haven't done the homework to
know exactly this sounds like your
emotion more than fast and you would do
your contract based on the of the cell
of your home too Debbie so all the funds
would translate be contingent yeah
which which again would add a level in
the Clause of the person if they're up
against you and then a cash offer that's
overpriced with no contingencies then
sure they're probably going to pick a
different
um buyer than you guys you know possibly
so there's that but the beauty of the
cooling Market is that it's not as
competitive as it is yeah yeah
I think there's a lot of fear you're
able to do that you're able to oh yeah
to do the transfer of funds though Vera
I just want you to hear that Debbie like
you're gonna yes your house has to sell
but I I'm confident that it will uh yeah
and you guys just be smart about what
you want to buy your budget for what you
want to buy and then you guys yeah put
your house on the market again
contingent upon the sale of your home
and then once it all goes through in a
perfect world obviously that your house
sells and then the home that you guys
have are under contract for to buy in
your budget everything just flows right
Downstream and it's great but it also W2
there's no there's no urgency the the
main motivation for you guys is that
it's just too much house and you feel
like we're not using it six bedrooms
it's just us so yeah there's no rush to
sell but I would think yeah there isn't
and even the realtor told me he said
maybe we should go down a little bit and
reduce the price a little bit and I'm
like I'm not that motivated yeah so
you're not in a you're not in a problem
that you need to sell right now yeah and
that's a good thing but also you've got
to Grapple with this fear you have of
change and what what if and what if and
what if and instead start to look at the
facts with your realtor and go all right
here's what we can do here's the house
that we can buy with this much money so
that we can retire next year instead of
seven years from now and there's going
to be some compromises with that but you
can do it at your own pace because
you're not desperate
I'm willing to compromise that's why I'm
talking to you guys we are the
compromise what's your husband want to
do Debbie real quick does he want to
sell and get out
my husband yeah
no he loves his house he loves it okay
well that you guys need to get on the
same page first and foremost
this isn't he has to listen to me
complain about the traffic all the time
there we go that is true that traffic
would be squeaky we are just the grease
Debbie you work him down as a nurse
practitioner if you can switch uh
facilities even in a different
um clinic or we need a lot of Debbies
out there there's practitioning so thank
you for what you do Debbie appreciate it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Rachel
Cruz this hour you're listening to the
Ramsey Show give us a call and we'll
talk about your life and your money the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Reba joins us up next
in Amarillo Reba welcome to the show
hi hey how are you
oh
no it's just us Reba we're not mean no
oh okay yeah Ken Coleman's not here Dr
John deloney's not here just a nice
piece definitely isn't here for sure
super nice this is a super nice show
today what's going on
Reba are you still there did she pass
out oh
goodness gracious I thought we lost you
okay how can we help today
what the question comes from you oh how
can we help the question
um my husband is such a tight one that
we were supposed to go out with the
congregation last night and break the
Feast for Yom Kippur which is also
called the Bay of atonement yes um for
uh for our beliefs and he when he he
showered and he
um got dressed but then when it was time
to go I told him how much the meal was
going to be 9.99 oh he couldn't spend
that much so my question was when is it
okay to start having a little fun or
spending a little money but that's not
your question your question is how do I
get my husband to stop being a tight wad
you know you can spend 9.99
yay are you guys what's your what's your
situation Reba give us how much debt do
you have
none none how much you have in savings
um none for me but for him I don't know
if he'd want me to tell you but he's got
a little Bank a little wad well if he
does then you do Reba you both are
married you have separate bank accounts
no
yes be on his bank account why no
because he's a tight wad I'm not allowed
to do anything all right so now I'm out
now we got it read The Works to support
herself as a wife to douglas douglas
hold on and you guys this is a married
couple we're talking how long have y'all
been married Reba
um we've been together for about 10
years but only been married about three
and a half I believe it is okay
so what is happening here is that you
guys are not aligned you're not working
as a team and what happens is even these
small signs yeah of not having the same
bank account him not wanting to share
with you all of that like what ends up
happening is it ends up integrating into
other parts of your marriage and so it's
big red flags in general that you guys
could have a much more intimate a much
more Dynamic a much more deeper
relationship if you guys trusted each
other on all levels and it doesn't sound
like you do
he doesn't he had bad a bad ex and I'm
getting all the blame okay
well until he deals with this baggage
this marriage is going to continue to
just be this weird mediocre roommate
situation
would you agree
yeah probably because that's what it
seems to be right now yeah can this old
dog learn new tricks Reba can we get him
to to go through Financial Peace
University with you to maybe get some
counseling together
I don't know okay you said you're
getting to go to counseling and I
haven't been successful yet okay
um what what spiritual affiliation are
you guys you said the day of atonement
all of that is
this is Messianic okay yep
um okay so I would get do you guys is it
a rabbi you have or a pastor Messianic
Jew I mean I'm familiar with that but
who Rabbi well we have people in the
congregation couples that take turns
doing a lesson
um we don't actually
uh have a rabbi up front Okay but I was
going to say just getting with someone I
mean you guys are have a spiritual
Community that's why I leans that way
first but even just good um yeah good
marriage you know counseling or therapy
which again he he's a adult so he's
going to decide uh if he wants to go or
not but I think one of the best things
that you can do Reba though is is have a
conversation with him
and tell him how you're feeling and why
you're feeling the ways you're feeling
and so just saying like we are I feel
like we're not enjoying life I feel like
things are so separate because they are
when it comes to our money and here's
what I want like here's the vision I
want for our marriage here's what I long
um to be as your wife here's what I want
as a husband here's what here's what
this looks like for me and why I want
that I want stability I want to be able
to do this life together and be a team
when we took vows you know what was it
three and a half years ago that that
this is what this is what I'm looking
for what I really want from you so tell
me what you're hearing and have this
conversation back and forth but I would
really have a heart to heart a serious
conversation with him that's more than
just the money and the more like and
more than just he won't spend 9.99 on a
meal uh this is going this is going
deeper does that make sense yes
okay yep
so and I want this for you guys
thank you I do too
but it's been a battle it's been a long
uphill battle I hear that well
especially when there's you know past
trauma and x's and this is how I grew up
experiencing money and now you're very
tight-fisted with it because you don't
want to get hurt again and so that's
where he seems to be coming from which
is understandable but we can't keep
living that way and you shouldn't pay
the price
for what had happened in the past either
do you know what I mean so
um yeah so I think you guys have some
some real heart-to-heart conversations
coming up soon
um and then that's what I would
encourage and then if there's any way
for him to love you as his wife and just
say as my husband will you please
um sit down and watch this first video
we're going to send you Financial Peace
University so hold on hang on the line
Reba and Austin will pick up
um and and you guys even just sit down
and watch the first one or two videos
together that that'll jump start you on
the financial side but if you can get
him uh to get a third party involved to
sit down and just have some some good
marriage marriage counseling marriage
therapy I think is one of the best
things ever because they they are able a
good therapist will be able to dig
underneath the surface of all of this
ask you good questions there's a lot of
self-reflection and understanding why
I'm doing things I'm doing and it's just
healthy
um so if you're able to do that I think
it's a real gift absolutely and if he's
unwilling to watch 45 minutes of a
lesson of Financial Peace University
then I think we need to take those more
drastic measures and go listen I cannot
continue like this being roommates I
signed up for this because I want to
become one yeah to have this level of
intimacy in relationship and money is
just a symptom of so much else going on
there and Reba don't say oh my God what
was his name douglas douglas don't say
Douglas you're a cheap Wad and I think
you need to watch this video right we
don't go after it with insults or with
sarcasm or anything truly with your
heart to ask his wife being as honest
and as vulnerable as you can be with him
um is a great place to start that
conversation because it can be easy to
point fingers and
it's one thing when you're you know 21
and getting married and this is all new
it's another when you're older and
you're in a different season of life and
you have all this baggage that you never
really dealt with and now you're just
hanging on to it all that's a much
harder thing to unpack and because
there's just decades and Decades of this
trauma that you haven't dealt with I'm
also going to throw in a copy of own
your past change your future along with
um Financial Peace University that's our
friend Dr John deloney's book and I
think a lot of this has to do with his
past and until we deal with that it's
going to be hard to affect our future
positively so hang on the line Reba and
we will make sure to gift you that book
John was just in the control room we
should have just had him jump in yeah I
know right before and here's what's
fascinating always about this about this
show in this topic George of money is is
money problems are never money problems
it's never what ends up happening right
we think that oh it's an issue here and
he won't spend the money but under a lot
of money problems is life stuff
happening and getting to the root system
is so important because money just
magnifies right who we are it amplifies
who we are and that's what it does and
so you've got to figure out at the root
of who am I and what is this amplifying
and so it's it's important work to do
yeah we can't just look at the external
surface issues there's always something
bubbling underneath and we got to deal
with that but it's so so worth it and we
hear this with debt-free screams on the
stage we try to get our money right and
all of a sudden our marriage improved
yep and there's a direct correlation
there because you have to deal with
things like communication and values and
how we operate when it comes to money so
do this stuff it's so worth it we're
cheering you on Reba this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
this is the Ramsay show you can give us
a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Justin joins us up
next in Charleston West Virginia Justin
welcome to the show
hey guys how are you doing well how are
you
a little nervous but not so bad uh
you'll be all right buddy what's going
on
so my wife and I
got married five days ago whoa congrats
congrats are you calling us from the
honeymoon
uh no after
okay good
where'd you go
forward we took a little trip a little
trip up to Cincinnati for a few days we
went to the zoo saw a couple sites had
some barbecues it was a good trip nice
how can we help today on the way back on
the way back we were talking
about like uh how we want to structure
the marriage uh we talked about money
talked about uh time with kids stuff
like that uh and I'm not very good with
money so I figured I would call and see
if you guys had any advice about the
good path to set out on second build a
good future for me and my family I'm
proud of you man thanks for the call
it's a great question so do you guys
have kids
um I she has a son I use my stepson he's
three years old and we have a uh a
little girl on the way she'll be here in
January congratulations okay so you're
just you want to start this marriage off
on the right foot where's her head at
when it comes to money
um we're we're pretty well aligned
um especially now that she's pregnant uh
and we're married we're looking to save
fail for death uh and I'm a little a
little scared by all that's a little
intimidating sure well the good news is
our plan is real simple and you do
things one step at a time so we're not
going to overwhelmingly overwhelm you
with 17 different things to do we just
want to set you off in the right
direction and we are also going to give
to you guys Financial Peace University
one year of that so you can watch
through all nine lessons together get on
an every dollar budget and start making
a plan for your money and feeling that
progress so how much debt do you guys
have collectively
um we have just over twenty thousand
dollars in debt of that uh 50 of that is
in uh medical and student loans
and the other half is in uh
uh two vehicles okay
cool and how much money do you guys have
in the bank
um we have just over three thousand
dollars in the bank right now all right
and what's your household income are
both of you working outside the home
um I'm working full-time and she's
working part-time uh I make 914 every
two weeks I don't really know what that
translates to in a year and she makes
about 600 every two weeks
okay
so well our A1 you already have baby
step one done which is to save one
thousand dollars in a starter emergency
fund and so now we're going to be
tackling this twenty thousand dollars of
debt
awesome
um is
do I need to do anything differently
since the baby's coming should I have
more money put away we do want you to
kind of pause the intensity on the debt
payoff and save up until babies baby and
mom are home and they're safe and
healthy but as soon as that's done you
can still stockpile cash until then and
hopefully you don't need to touch much
of it and you can use that towards the
debt yeah Justin will she be going on
maternity leave at the beginning of the
year I'm assuming
yes she's going to get uh I believe 16
to 20 weeks okay is that paid or not
paid the first 12 is paid okay okay
that's great so yeah if I were you guys
um just in the very first there's kind
of like the Tactical approach if you
will and then more just the
philosophical approach so these are
tactical things we're talking about
right so when you guys um pick up with
Austin after this call I want you yet to
get the videos and to do your first
budget you guys sit down do your budget
together it's going to help your income
go so much further it's going to take a
lot of these questions that you have I
think out of the out of your head
because you're going to know exactly
where every dollar is going you're going
to feel in control maybe for the first
time ever
um and that budget really is your road
map month to month and you guys are
going to be able to look at those
numbers and say okay between now and
January we are gonna have a stockpile
money any extra money that we have we're
gonna cut some expenses do what we can
to get as much money as possible in the
bank and then like George said once baby
and mom come home
everything's good press play on that and
then start paying off your smallest debt
first so you said half is in medical and
student loans the other half are in two
cars split those in four debts list
those four smallest largest and you guys
start working on that smallest one and
okay and two Justin I would say that we
find that the people that get out of
debt
um the fastest are the ones that
sacrifice so that's sacrificing
lifestyle that's you possibly taking on
an extra job while she's home with the
baby
um maybe you're working you know a few
extra nights I mean doing what you can
to pay this off as much as possible and
as fast as possible because when you
guys don't have payments uh there's an
amazing thing that happens the amount of
stress when you don't owe anyone
anything uh you can really feel that and
I think it just it helps you
relationally too in your marriage
there's not this like oh this this
stress point that debt brings and so
that freedom is something I would work
towards so that's kind of the Tactical
side but I would also sit down and you
guys it sounds really cheesy Justin but
my husband and I we do it almost every
year and intentional we call it just
like a dream date night so we we go out
to dinner we leave the kids with the
babysitter or we go enjoy a nice meal
somewhere and we just honestly we just
dream we're like okay what is the next
five years gonna look like how old are
our kids going to be like we map out our
ages where everyone's going to be in
school and be like okay what what would
be the dream like what would be the
dream and out of the last dream meeting
we're like we would love a pool one day
we would love a pool and so we're like
okay should that be one of the things we
start saving for in the next five to six
years like do we want to put in a pool
one day you know it's like it's these
things that you just start looking at
and you think okay do we want to take a
vacation once a year with the kids to
the beach like whatever the thing is
that you guys want out of life and want
to be able to do with money eventually
like talk about it and just have fun
with it it doesn't have to be this
stressful gosh I'm not good at it she's
not good at it you know take stop using
that language you know you guys just
have a few date nights where you just
dream and then out of that Justin are
going to come a couple of things your
value systems are going to come out of
that to say okay what do we value as a
family
um goals are going to come out of that
to say man a goal could be you know
whatever you fill in the blank Justin
for what you guys want out of uh you
know the next few years of life you know
maybe for you guys a big goal to get out
of debt the next goal will be to get an
emergency fund after that in 10 years
what could a goal be you know I have
these things that you're shooting for
because that helps the motivation too
when it comes to money that when you're
making the sacrifices you're working
towards something and you guys working
as a team in that is huge uh I would
also talk about your fears like what
what is the fear that you have when you
say like I'm just not good with money I
just feel intimidated like share that
with her and be like I here's where I'm
at like it feels overwhelming to me I'm
fear that I'm fearful I'm gonna fail at
this
um I don't want to end up like my
parents like whatever the thing is like
talk about the Fears let her do the same
uh women's Number One Financial fear is
the lack of security so she may say oh
my gosh like I just want to make sure
we're going to be okay I have a new the
new babies coming like let her say those
things out loud like you guys when you
share in all of that emotion it's more
than just money uh this was the last
call we were even talking to last
segment like you know those
conversations that that is life
conversation that happens to be through
the Avenue and the lens of money oh yeah
um but you're you guys are just
deepening your relationship even in
those conversations so so that's what's
fun about money is there's a tactical
side that you guys can and have numbers
too and you're doing a budget and you
have a numbers goal that you're working
towards but there's also like that
philosophical side of you know what what
where do we want to be generous with our
money what do we want for our kids what
do we you know that that kind of
dreaming goal setting side as well which
I think brings couples together and when
you work together it it goes that much
faster and it's that much more fun it's
that much more fun to do the journey
together
great wisdom there from Rachel so Justin
how old are you two
um we are both 23 years old okay what
are you doing for work
uh I'm actually an EMT uh and she is
working at Walmart cool because I
noticed just doing the math I feel like
getting your income up would really help
because looking at was that take-home
pay numbers you were giving me or is
that gross pay
Compass okay because yours adds up to
about 23 you heard adds up to about 15.
so if we can get your take-home pay up
to relieve her because she's gonna you
know have this baby I don't know what
child care is going to look like and
work is going to look like but if you
can bust it and start to make 30 35 40
take-home pay and maybe that means
switching career paths completely
getting some education that's going to
help because your greatest wealth
building tool is your income
okay we're cheering you on man we're
gonna send you Financial Peace
University and I'm also going to get you
Ken Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose that's going to really help you
start dreaming about what that career
could look like because man it changes
the game when you can get that shovel up
and you can start digging out of this
hole a whole lot faster my man you got
it Justin we're excited for you this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz
this is the Ramsay show well Rachel it's
been an exciting week I'm honored to be
a part of one of your newest product
lines
thank you George I'm going to hand you
this box right here oh I get to be a
part of this we have three boxes in
front of us because this week yes we
launched the new Rachel Cruz slim wallet
so we have the original Cruise envelope
system
that it has built-in envelopes so when
you're budgeting early on you can cash
out categories that you tend to
overspend and it's a great wallet for
that now once you've moved past the
envelope system you use your debit card
mostly I just like the convenience of
having still one envelope to have cash
in but a place to put all my cards and
people on social media are like that's a
lot of card slots for people that don't
use credit cards no there is Costco
cards sure there are other debit cards
there are gift cards your insurance card
your license
there are other cards in the world
besides I wish if you put a credit card
in here it would like pop back out like
it would not allow it that would be
actually pretty cool technology yeah so
it's beautiful so it's just a slim
wallet holds your cards one and um one
area for one cash envelope and yeah it
just makes uh budgeting still easy and
and as a lady it's just convenience so
you ladies know if you're switching
personally every time it just it's
helpful I feel like my wife has to buy a
new purse every week I'm like don't you
she's like well this is a different one
because I need one that's smaller
because this one's too big I need the
strap on this one I know it's a thing
it's very stressful so these wallets
three colors three colors black
champagne it's like metallic gold and a
camel after named after me for George
you messed up the spelling though you
called it with a c I know on the website
we'll have to fix that terrible and I
got really excited because I opened mine
up and it had like hundred dollar bills
in it and then I realized this is fake
prop money fake money so if you order
one of these you will not find money
fake or real in there you can put your
own money in though because you follow
our plan that's right so these are
um real leather they're beautiful it
smells great and we partnered with our
friends at join that is a company out of
India and they hire uh people in all the
vulnerable communities of India to give
them trade and give them work it's a
really just it's a beautiful thing so
I'm so thankful that we get to partner
with them so go to Rachel or go to
ramseysolutions.com and get your Rachel
Cruz a slim wallet available today for
39 again three different colors and you
know we're just making tools for your
money we're just we're just helping the
whole process out I love it well you
know having something beautiful that can
remind you about your journey you know
you see RC on there you're like that's
right yeah I'm not gonna make a bad
spending decision because Rachel wants
me to win with money that's right I love
it well congratulations fun week George
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Scott is joining us all the way from
Phoenix Arizona Scott welcome to the
show
hey good afternoon it's nice talking to
you both you as well yeah thanks so I've
got a real mess on my hands um before
Friday of last week life seemed pretty
peachy and after Friday it got messy I
got a basically a home invasion a
burglary and my primary residence and ah
I can wrap my head around the things
that were stolen the material things the
high value things but I'm having a
really difficult time wrapping my head
around the sophistication of the the
feast the breaking into you know home
safes and stealing all of our personal
documents
passports ID card my son and our birth
certificates bank statements sort of all
that
and I'm just curious I really value your
advice and I'm curious if there's
anything proactively other than reaching
out to my bank and whatnot that I can do
to prevent any future and I'm sure it's
coming but any kind of identity theft
that will manifest itself
um
I'm so sorry to hear about that Scott
that is I mean on top of just
frustrating and heartbreaking it's scary
I mean it's just you can't feel safe
yeah yeah exactly well a lot of
emotional baggage but it's kind of being
proactive and thinking about you know
how we can get in front of this other
than you know we have insurance we can
cover the material things but it's bad
do you guys have identity theft
Insurance by chance
so no in that regard but I do monitor
that the bureaus pretty frequently and
check uh scores and things like that so
I don't know if that's equivalent
probably not
well have you put a fraud alert on all
of your credit accounts
yes we've done that piece okay um and
you put a freeze on them as well
we yes we put a freeze on everything we
have new cards checkbooks coming out
um
or like passports and social security
cards they're all going
yeah you'll need to contact the Social
Security Administration and get that
sorted out and let them know what's
going on
but outside of that the the main issue
is going to be the financial piece of
this and so if you've got a freeze on
your credit report with all three credit
bureaus you said you've done that
no I haven't done that piece yet so
that's okay kind of next I was curious
if that's that is a something we should
take as a step obviously that's very
important because then the number one
thing that's going to happen is they're
going to try to create new accounts with
your identity and I've had this happen
to me and so I can tell you from
personal experience not the home
invasion part but the identity theft
part and people are creating accounts
with my social security number old
addresses and so putting a freeze on
those credit bureaus will stop those
from happening have you filed a police
report I'm guessing
oh yeah yeah we've got that done and
they actually caught somebody but there
were there were several involved oh
that's great one person in custody yeah
it is great well it'll be great to get
some of those documents back too if
they're uh if they can get those
George did you go directly to the bureau
website or how did you do that yes go to
each of the websites um Experian
TransUnion Equifax and you can start
that process and on top of the police
report and freezing all of your credit
with all the bureaus file a report with
the Federal Trade Commission the FTC you
can do that on their website as well to
notify them
okay
good and then of course you're going to
be diligently checking bank and any kind
of card statements obviously you're
going to want new cards new accounts I
would just go through that whole process
to be safe and do you have any debt
yeah no well that's not true we have a
little mortgage okay I just want to make
sure there wasn't debt floating out
there uh as well because you'd want to
get any of the fraudulent account
records from debt collectors
and you've already contacted your bank
do you have more than one Bank
you do okay we've contacted all of them
and then your utility providers
you'd want to contact them as well
okay and then of course passwords and
usernames which that one may be the most
frustrating because you don't even
remember the passwords to have this
stuff
yeah no kidding but that's that's A1
because if they get in your email that's
a whole nother situation
okay so I've got a resource for you at
Ramsey Solutions uh on identity what to
do if your identity is stolen if you
search those words you'll find it on
there it's about a a 14-minute listen uh
you can hear me read it or you can just
read it yourself but that'll go through
all of that we just had to fly through
it on air for sake of radio time but man
I'm so sorry sorry Scott that's such a
hassle and for the future today I would
go check out our friends at Xander they
have ID Theft Protection luckily when I
had this happen to me I had just started
working at Ramsay and I contacted them
and they were on my behalf were cleaning
up this mess for me because it can take
dozens and dozens and dozens of hours
just to message it's like a part-time
job yeah because there's so much so many
angles there's so many things so I'm so
sorry Scott
thank you guys yeah it's a real
nightmare but uh we'll get through it
yep
absolutely I hope that helps man that's
such a tough situation just
heartbreaking so hard
especially with home invasion identity
theft alone is frustrating and scary but
a home invasion is way too personal oh
gosh yeah oh my goodness
um do you guys have a lot like cameras
are you one of those family I'm sure
Winston because he's a big privacy nerd
oh he loves his technology so we got
three different types of cameras George
wow from like internet based not
internet based like it's the Wi-Fi
we got it all the bases covered producer
James loves that he's he's big on this
stuff
James isn't even his real name we don't
even know this man is so good but me and
James do taught privacy a lot I'm like I
got a leg in it because I'm interested
and I love the technology yeah and I've
dealt with this stuff and it's not yes
I've never had my I've never had a I've
never dealt with a home invasion so sure
I've never had that yeah happen
um but there's only so much you can do
and that's what's scary too is like
I mean yeah so you have the camera so
maybe you can kind of catch the people
but
you know yeah there's it's just a fact
of life unfortunately but there are a
lot of things you can do to protect
yourself especially on the financial
side right on on the logistical side of
it yes all that for sure for sure Scott
buddy I'm hoping the best for you to
clean this up as quickly as possible get
ID Theft Protection today people from
our friends at Xander it is super super
cheap it'll protect your entire family
and it is so so worth it that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books my
thanks to everyone in Booth Austin and
Ben and Zach and James and Andrew
whoever's in there who knows Nathan and
of course you America we appreciate you
listening and Jade fellow Ramsey
personality we'll be back with you
before you know it
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz and we
are excited to take your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Alex is kicking us off
in St Louis Alex welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi good afternoon thanks for having me
absolutely uh I'm uh I'm gonna be a
first time home buyer here at the end of
the year and I'm trying to figure out
how to choose the right lender and in my
search for the right lender my local
credit union gave me a different option
I wasn't really expecting where instead
of PMI they would
add interest rate a small amount of
interest to the interest rate of vote
mortgage loan and I'm not really sure if
that's working
and I don't like the sound of that are
they talking about Mortgage points
uh the way they phrase it was instead of
having PMI if you're between five and
ten percent down payment they would add
a quarter point to the interest rate and
if it's 10 to 20 down payment it would
be point one percent to the interest
rate
um
well are you in a place financially to
buy a house
uh I am debt free as of March following
Dave Ramsey's uh Financial theories and
uh since then I've been saving up I have
about 20 000 saved up for closing and
down payment
costs uh it's not quite 20 but my
housing situation is changing early next
year so I figured this would be a good
time to accelerate things and just go
and bite the bullet okay well the issue
with the PMI I'm seeing is PMI would go
away once you have enough equity in the
home whereas this added to your interest
rate would just be there forever
I could refinance it they said after
that 20 percent but uh you could but it
would then incur more closing time
fair enough
so I just don't I don't see that as a
good option
um I would still shop around I mean
obviously our friends at Churchill
Mortgage are going to treat you well and
so that's a good starting point if you
want to see what all they'll give you
the whole rundown on the sheet of here's
every single fee involved they'll walk
you through it and they have the heart
of a teacher over there and they'll make
sure you understand what every single
line means
okay so as far as picking A lender I
mean at the end of the day it is about
the numbers but it's also about the
customer service how they treat you how
they educate you how they walk with you
along the journey and I've had an
amazing experience personally with
Churchill and I learned a ton in the
process too yeah they're there to
definitely answer your questions so yeah
you want someone that's
um yeah willing to to teach you and to
understand exactly what's happening so
yeah the the added
percentage of the interest rate all that
I'm kind of with George where I'm like
man are you able to put 10 10 down Alex
as you say or five
it would be close to ten I could
probably make 10 work depends on the
final cost of the house sure sure is
this on a 30 year or a 15.
a 15-year fixed rate okay awesome that's
great Alex well congratulations yeah
that's all I mean you've done you've
done the hard work at this point so yeah
I think it's just picking A lender that
we always say whenever you're um making
a big decision whether it's like with
investing or helping you know someone
with your taxes or insurance or
mortgages like these big areas of our
money making sure that someone has the
heart of a teacher
um that yeah you don't feel like slimy
by or anything that you just actually
like the person and the math works right
so like both is are the win and that's
what Churchill really does provide uh
like George was saying but yeah shop
around
um look at the math but yeah the credit
union uh deal I would run the numbers on
what it would be for PMI but then yeah
if you if you have to go and refinance
like you're saying you have to like
closing costs and we don't know what
even the mortgage rates are going to be
at that point I don't know I just I I
would just I would just do the 15-year
fix with the PMI and be able to get to
that 20 uh and then that will go away
thanks for the call Alex appreciate it
man congratulations thank you
congratulations first time homeowner and
everything it's a big step in adulthood
for sure all right Shannon is up next in
Idaho Falls Shannon welcome to the show
thank you guys so much for taking my
call yeah happy to take it what's going
on
um I have a couple of questions so I
recently became a stay-at-home mom
and
um I am needing to roll over my 401k
from my last employer
um I know right now it's the market you
don't obviously you don't want to take
anything out because it's low you want
to write it but I don't know if that
counts for waiting on a 401K rollover if
it's gonna make any difference if I wait
a little bit or do I just go with it and
just get it rolled over even though it's
a lot less than it was six months ago
yeah I would go ahead and roll it over
to a traditional IRA Shannon out of your
company and just have it in there and
yeah and just and you write it out so
yeah definitely don't cash it out and I
would not leave it in your company I
would roll it over just to a traditional
IRA so the strings are cut it's just you
and that money and you're just gonna
ride the roller coaster for the next few
decades yeah and this was a traditional
401K that you had uh it was a Ross okay
okay okay so you could do a direct
rollover into a Roth IRA without any
penalties which as I would yes I would
do that right and you can contact a
smartvest for Pro on our website and
they can walk you through that process
says I did that with an old 401k from a
previous employer when I started here
and they made it super simple and so now
it's just sitting there and it's in my
control and you have way more options so
I like that plan do you have another
question as well
um yes my husband is self-employed and
technically I am as well because we own
it 50 50 50.
um we I do have a Roth IRA that we're
doing for him and so obviously I need to
start doing that
um one thing I wasn't 100 sure of is how
do you decide what 15 of your monthly
income is when you're self-employed and
all the expenses are different and we
we're debt free we own our house
outright we've followed all of those
steps but I don't know how to decide
what the exact amount is that we should
be investing every month for the 15
percent
well I would be looking at the business
in your personal as two different you
know two different entities if you will
and so out of the business you guys have
to decide hey what's the salary we're
going to pay ourselves or what's a
commission a percentage
of the net profit that we have that
we're going to pay so you kind of need a
formula for you guys of what you're
going to consistently pay yourself so
that you know and again it can be
commission based percentage-wise or it
can just be a flat salary that sounds
good that works with the business but I
would make it a very clean transfer
meaning like hey we've decided this
amount so we know that it's this
percentage of the of the net revenues or
um this salary and it's that consistent
so that you have the ability to say okay
we know exactly what the take-home pay
is because sometimes with a small
business those things are merged so
often and we want to separate those to
make it very very clear of what's in the
business and what are we paying out of
the business but you guys own it so you
get to decide so you don't want to
overpay yourselves because that will
harm the business but you also don't
want to underpay yourself because you
wouldn't do that if you're working
somewhere else yeah and with a regular
income we're just going to invest 15 of
what that month's income was maybe this
month is 3 000 next month is 4 000 but
at the end of the year you will still
have invested 15 of your total income so
uh way to go congratulations on on this
new season that you're in being a
stay-at-home mom and the success of this
business we're cheering you on this is
the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show this is
your show America give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
friendly reminder now that fall break is
hitting here in uh across the country
you can come visit us at our
headquarters right here south of
Nashville Tennessee we've had a great
time uh coming out about two times an
hour meeting folks from all around
hearing their stories we've got free
cookies free coffee we've got free mugs
pretty much everything's free except for
the bookstore you can purchase products
as well and there's a cool timeline wall
kind of the Ramsey Museum I guess you
can call it yeah and it's a really cool
headquarters and Nashville is a great
City so come visit us our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself why they're the number one
online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping and with new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code Ramsay to get the best
deal today's question comes from Mark in
New Jersey last year my wife and I made
over 310
000 and this year we've made 250
thousand dollars but we have still
little to no savings last night I
decided to finally dig into it when I
came what I came up with after doing
this is that there was about a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars blown on who
knows what this was a team effort that I
think we equally contributed to every
time I have a conversation with my wife
about money it seems to end up being a
fight she's a very rational person so
I'm sure it's the way I'm approaching it
how do I bring it up without causing a
huge flat fight and allowing us to make
a massive change wow it's a good
question mark
um yeah I love that he was like I'm
gonna investigate all right turns out we
blew 120 Grand on I have no clue I don't
know what yes man that's what happens
yeah I mean I think I would start the
conversation with you know it I think in
a humble way Mark I think there's always
something you know with the humility
side of like man I have I have
contributed to this which you've already
met it and and I've messed this up too
like I have not
um done a great job communicating with
you I haven't done a great job uh
staying on top of our money and making
this a priority so I'm sorry like
there's just a level of humility there
and accountability yeah that I think is
a really beautiful way to approach it's
very disarming when you do that and you
kind of own your own stuff and you have
this level of like I didn't get it right
um and then obviously not letting her
you know just
[Music]
yeah I mean like you know letting it
start to be a conversation though of
like okay so what do we want this to
look like now what do we as a team want
to look and have a vision for our
marriage and what are our goals what are
we what are we wanting to do because you
make great income like you're saying and
to be able to say man let's just take
this further and do it and do it on
purpose you know it's okay to still
spend money that's one thing that people
think the Ramsay plan is like you can't
spend any money no you can once you
don't have debt and you have an
emergency fund you've taken care of what
you need to take care of you can spend
money and enjoy so it's
um I think it's having that conversation
of like hey what does this look like for
us and let's still enjoy our lives well
let's do it on purpose with
intentionality amen Rachel I wish you
could just have that conversation you
know what Mark you know you can do it
for you but what this comes down to is
not going we have to get our budget
today and you're really screwing this up
it starts with that Vision where you go
hey what are our goals for the year
because I feel like we've been floating
and we have nothing to show for it we
make amazing money more than we ever
thought we would and here we are with
nothing in the bank and it's all just
stuff and food and shopping and I I feel
like I've done a terrible job leading Us
in that way and so I want to set some
goals in our life and once you set those
goals well now we have to make changes
and change some habits in order to
actually achieve those goals and one of
those is we got to get on a budget yeah
and not to you know constrict us but to
give us freedom so that when we do spend
we do it with confidence with no regret
and we're not derailing our goals that's
right now it's a different conversation
no rag rats which we mentioned that in
our in smart money happy hour I
explained to Rachel I said it was an
internet meme it's beyond that of course
it's for a scene from where The Millers
and Rachel was like okay what now it's a
great one it's a great clip go check
that out so thank you for the question
mark this is not going to be easy but
man it's going to be worth it and I
think if you approach it with that
humility and accountability it will go a
long long way all right Bridget joins us
up next on the phones in Philadelphia
Bridget welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely what's going on
well so I'm in about uh 18
000 worth of debt
um I only made about uh 2 200 a month
and
um I can pay all my bills including my
minimum payments for my credit cards
which is fantastic however
um per month so I make about
um 2 200 and my build in total are about
1
150 or so every single month I take out
about six hundred dollars in just plain
cash for my cash wallet so I don't spend
any extra money and I have about
450 remaining
so my question is
should I put all of that extra money
into credit card payments or should I
save some of that money to add to my
savings because I only have a little
over a thousand dollars in savings but
my problem is I don't have any extra
money for
um like car maintenance or even just
like yearly things like car registration
and things like that so I'm not really
sure what to do with that extra cash
that I have
great question and you've been doing a
great job paying attention to your money
um knowing exactly what you have doing
the envelope system so you're on a roll
here and it's a great question when it
comes to those kind of yearly
maintenance expenses and we would label
those as sinking funds in your budget to
where you would add ten dollars a month
so at the end of the year you have 120
to pay your car registration
okay absolutely so that that's something
I actually have binders for that I just
haven't actually contributed the money
towards that so I have everything
prepared I just haven't actually gotten
to that point
um so so that that's helpful because I
do worry that I'm not going to have the
money to be able to do those things and
it's great to have an emergency fund but
sometimes I look at the emergency fund
as like a true true emergency yeah not
something that I should have been
planning for for sure
um Bridget what do you do for a living
well um so I'm actually a supervisor for
a call center for one of the State uh
professional licensing department okay
for doctors nurses Etc okay that's great
um because I'm just looking at your
income and it's coming out to about
twenty six thousand dollars a year does
that sound about right
oh yeah unfortunately yeah well I mean
I'm just I'm just saying that you know
um
the way to look at money is it flows two
ways it flows in and it flows out and
that flowing in part your income it's a
part of the equation just to look at and
factor into and
um there's obviously something to be
said about a wonderful work environment
and enjoying what you do having joy in
it all of that but also you want to make
sure that that it's paying you and that
you can get ahead financially
um because you know living in
Philadelphia I know I'm sure that you
know that's a expensive it's an
expensive part of of the country as well
yeah so absolutely I don't know have you
thought about maybe shifting jobs to
because I mean you can make
double that
I would think somewhere else maybe not
doing exactly the same thing but any
type of job have you looked at other
leadership and supervisor roles that you
could apply for well so
um in terms of a job know however I am
looking into going to school for
something in computer science my mother
is absolutely wonderful and offered to
pay for my schooling that's a gift yeah
that's great so I am doing that so that
I can get more money because I know I'm
just I'm making enough to pay my bills
but I'm not making enough to pay them
off completely and to really just enjoy
living and saving and saving that nature
yeah for sure yeah so I I mean that
would be something I would consider too
because again it's just part half of the
equation
um to get you even just further to pay
off this 18 000 but yeah so besides the
sinking funds that extra 450 a month
um I would for sure say current on all
of your payments
um and then anything extra you have be
throwing it at that smallest debt
whether it's a credit card or whatever
it may be so
um but again getting that income up I
think is going to really help you put
gas on this and in the meantime it may
look like side hustles and you know food
delivery grocery delivery you name it
there's a lot of things out there you
could do I mean even the call center
World customer service there's things
you can do nights and weekends to
increase income for now but that's going
to really make you feel some progress
with this debt-free journey because
right now you're just chipping away at
it and I want you to take a sludge
hammer to that yeah you're doing a great
job if you have that same motivation the
exact same attitude you have but having
more money and dollar signs on top of it
you're going to get through it so much
faster deep sacrifice for a short period
of time it is so worth it thanks for the
call Bridget this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well it's no secret we love talking
money around here but we know not
everyone feels that way and that's why
Rachel Cruz and myself started thinking
about what it would be like to talk
money for those who would just rather
have some fun
and so we decided we can mix the two we
can make money fun again Rachel so last
week we launched our new Ramsay podcast
called smart money happy hour where
Rachel and I dig into the stuff you and
your friends would talk about or you
wish they would talk about at a weekly
happy hour things like pop culture
what's going on in the world and how to
afford a life you love it's fun casual
money advice that will make you feel
less stressed and More in control of
your money plus there are some hilarious
moments that you do not want to miss we
promise you'll also Walk Away Learning
something this week's episode dropped
today it's all about Disney adults
Disney trauma and why they priced out
the middle class and uh I take the brunt
of it on the trauma part Rachel I was
very honest with my Disney trauma you'll
have to listen in to figure out what
happened there so if you love Disney
hate Disney this episode is for you it's
wildly entertaining go ahead and follow
or subscribe to Smart money happy hour
wherever you listen to podcasts new
episodes come out every Thursday and you
won't miss one if you hit that follow
button check it out all right Bill joins
us up next in Dayton Ohio Bill Welcome
to the the show
thank you
what's going on
thanks for taking my call Hey so uh yeah
I got my dream job a remote job a couple
months ago and so now I get to uh leave
Cold Florida and move to cold Ohio I'm
sorry and moved to Florida awesome nice
um
yeah so um I've been doing some house
hunting
um I've got a contract on my paid for
home here in Ohio
and everything that kind of seemed to
fit my uh what I want down there is
around the 700 000 mark
so I'm going to get about 289 from my
current house and I've got about 335 in
the bank
so that puts that puts me at like 626 so
I'm gonna have to get a small mortgage
because
um you know I want to
put it all down
so the reason I'm calling is try to
figure out how much should I keep in my
emergency fund
um you know and how much should I put
down on the house so I make about
215k a year and 65 of that's from
military retirement so it's
passive income cool and will that change
once you're in Florida
oh no okay same income same income well
it'll drop a little bit the income will
drop about four thousand a year just
because of the locality so what is your
monthly expenses
to cover all of the the normal bills
maybe a few of the subscriptions some of
those luxuries what would it take to
cover one month uh yeah so I figured
that out yesterday driving back and uh
it comes out to about uh
twenty four hundred dollars a month okay
and do you have are you married Bill
kids
uh grown kids and single right now with
a great girlfriend okay okay
so yeah I mean yeah it comes out to
about yeah 62. 100
um
I would go for six months if I'm in your
shoes yeah I would put I would I think
I'd put probably 10 down
um because you are single you don't have
kids all that like I think I think you
have a great income so if an emergency
came up you could cash flow a lot so I
would probably just hold 10 bill for an
emergency fund and then yeah I would and
then put the rest yeah towards this
mortgage which is amazing
um well done bill it's I mean this is
this is pretty incredible that you're
able to do this
yeah I'm I'm I'm happy to be in a happy
to be a Ramsey uh
um success story oh that's awesome
absolutely incredible do you have
anything in retirement
oh yeah I've got uh probably another
800 000 in retirements yeah so you're an
everyday millionaire crushing it yes
ma'am baby steps millionaire well done
we love it Well Done Bill well Bill they
all the other truth is that if your
expenses go up you could easily save
another five thousand in there within a
month or two with your income yeah
that's true in Florida I think it is
more worth yeah once you get over there
and if you feel a little bit insecure
about you know the emergency fund just
go up to that six months which would be
closer to 15 and call it a day but
you're in a great spot man thanks for
the call all right coming up we've got
Digger in Greenville South Carolina
Digger welcome to the show
thanks
um I am a public school teacher and uh I
think about 66 000 a year
um and then a couple of bumps in the
road over the last couple years
um and my real question is I got the
thousand dollars in my uh in my savings
the emergency fund and uh I I don't have
a whole lot extra per month to throw it
my debt and my employer won't let me
stop contributing to my retirement
they're mandating that I can't opt out
and I have to give nine percent to it
every month that's the minimum is 90.
I'm wondering if I'm
sometimes is the minimum nine percent
yeah that has to give nine percent okay
and this is slowing down your debt free
Journey
um I'm I'm not I I mean I really want to
go at this and get my deck on but it
just seems like I'm not I don't have
enough
to really put a significant event in
anything how much debt do you have
uh
well
um South Carolina has I know back taxes
at 4 100.
um my car loan is 6700 uh the federal
government wants 12 100 and my credit
cards at 18 000. what do you mean by
federal government
I yeah I sold the house and uh didn't
save enough back for uh the taxes I
would owe on the profit and so I'm still
paying off so you owe about over 16
total to the IRS
um well South Carolina wants 4 100 and
the feds want 12 100 so together it's
like 16 too okay and any other debt
besides that in the car loan
credit cards uh uh credit card yeah okay
well I mean you have a great income it
stinks that they're mandating this nine
percent it does slow you down because
that nine percent could have been going
towards your debt but is there any way
you could increase seven hundred dollars
I'm sorry so how can we make up for that
700 through working more could you tutor
substitute teach do side hustles in
order to create 700 a month
to speed up this process I can't I mean
my my job is seven to four every day and
I can't so I can't substitute and
tutoring is not really an option here um
it's a very rural community I live in so
something like that I was thinking of
getting a second job or something like
that you could do weekends um
yeah I heard you say something about
csrs or something like that where I
could work from home that sort of thing
yeah yeah I know looking looking at this
digger I mean you said
um that you've had some bumps in the
road and stuff and so it's it's been
probably been a long journey for you and
you're probably exhausted feeling like I
should be further along than I am and so
I'm sure there's just frustration and
annoyance of even these taxes I mean all
of it right it's not it's not fun to
look at these numbers and you're not
like oh man but there's a but there's
five years ago I owned my own home and I
had zero debt and the I lost my job for
the 14 months due to a hospital work
environment and that's where the credit
card went to 18 000 and then I got the I
didn't sign up about the taxes from the
federal government in the state and
it'll hit me all at once and then bought
a car and you know believing I was gonna
work at my place I mean I love what I do
but just every everything hit me at once
and you know that's what but you know I
was I was ready to do the panther house
or the you know the live Dead free and
all that stuff and I didn't get nailed
with 40 000 worth of debt I'm so sorry
hard to stay positive yep because I'm
single and I'm 50 and yep yeah
no totally I I hear you and it feels
like it's that it's that season of life
where it's like something goes wrong
everything goes wrong we kind of laugh
and say when Murphy hits it's like his
brother and his other brother move in
with you right and it's just like oh my
God does life just keep kicking me when
I'm down and it's that feeling but you
know what we've seen these we've seen
numbers just like this before on the
debt-free stage and they do it and it's
gonna take some time but I want you to
map it out and say hey if I took a
weekend job how much do I need to make
and how long would it take me to pay
this off and when you have facts in
front of you too it takes the emotion
out and it helps you stay motivated so
hang on the line we're gonna give you
Total Money Makeover uh one of the best
books to help you get re-motivated in
all of this uh and you can do this
Digger you can do this
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day Philippians 2 4
Let each of you look not only to his own
interests but also to the interests of
others
Chris Pratt said I'm a man of faith and
I believe that God works in mysterious
ways and gives us signs and Gifts in
life and those gifts oftentimes come in
the form of people oh that's George
that's your gift to my life wow look at
that I feel about that I didn't know
that was we were going there but I
really appreciate it yes thank you nice
friendship we have here James never says
that to me so James are we a gift in
your life totally are oh he's a great
actor Chris Pratt and James both great
actors all right I'm George Campbell
she's Rachel Cruz this is the Ramsay
show triple eight eight two five five
two two five Alex joins us up next in
Virginia Beach Alex welcome to the show
hey guys thank you very much yeah how
can we help today
yes I I'm 24 years old I recently
graduated college and I've always been
Forward Thinking so I'm trying to save
money as a down payment for a house
awesome but I have this addiction of
investing and with the market going down
month over month I just can't stop
transferring money to my brokerage
account and buying index funds and so
for like a year now my savings account
slash emergency fund slash
down payment for a house has really just
stayed at like between six and eight
thousand and from my investing account
has grown quite a bit
cool and so what's your question for us
today
is very like a behavior an emotional
uh idea like a concept I can change
about how I'm thinking about this to
stop the investing or like a
mathematical
reason I should save cash instead of
enabling and buying these dips every
every two weeks or so and just get on
the get on the wagon and start
increasing this security deposit well I
think part of the problem is math is
what got us into this thing because you
were looking at the investment going
well I can make way more money in the
market than it's sitting in a bank
account right
Yeah well yeah over time you're excited
to like Buy Low is that what's happening
too it's like this exciting game to you
yeah especially right now yeah down 20
year-to-date 25 since January yep yep
really well when do you want to buy a
house
probably at least a year from now okay
maybe closer to three because I'm just a
single guy right now so I don't feel
like a two-bedroom house would be
necessary and condos aren't really
appealing so I would prefer three or
more years from now maybe yeah
well I think Alex there's something I'm
just curious of your I understand that
like man it's kind of this game it's
kind of exciting in a weird way because
the market is down and you're like oh my
gosh I can put money in here and then if
it goes up here I'm gonna make this much
more and it's there's like a kind of
this adrenaline feeling that you're
doing and you're not doing anything
dangerous I mean you're buying index
funds you know but a lot of our
long-term strategy with investing is to
be like okay we're gonna just ride it
out and have a steady plan of investing
15 of our income and kind of just
staying with that instead of playing
this this game that you're it's it's
like an emotional thing for you to do
um and again it's not terrible you're
not like going and buying all these
you know single stocks and all that I
mean the index fund it's it's you're not
going to Vegas here you're not blowing
the money you're doing too much of a
good thing and it's turning into a bad
thing
yeah and so I would refocus it on those
goals that you have which is I want to
buy a house and in three years from now
I don't want to look up and I have the
same number in my portfolio because the
market kept dipping up and down which is
why we say hey if you've got a short
time Horizon don't invest if you're
going to be purchasing a home in the
next three years put it in a high yield
savings account and the point is not for
the money to grow the point is to
protect what you're trying to grow in
that savings account yeah so I think
Alex if you had more of a
um time frame with buying a house
because I feel like you're a
goal-oriented person and so shooting for
something tangible is motivating and
yeah I just don't feel like you have
that right now right because you're like
I could buy a house in a year it could
be three years I'm seeing I mean so
there's you don't have this big why to
keep money I mean I don't want you to
drain an emergency fund by any means
um but you almost need to figure out
this new a new goal for you and I don't
know if it's just a dollar amount
um and maybe you you direct that dollar
amount towards the down payment later
down the road but like my husband is
like this Alex he is a numbers guys like
at the end of the year I want x amount
in the in the money market account that
I can see and it's like that's
motivating for him and for me I'm like I
want to know the why what are we going
to do with that are we gonna go on
vacation with it is it going to just sit
there if it sits there that's great I
just need to know what we're doing with
it so I don't know if it's a number for
you that's kind of more of a fun game to
say hey I want to put this much away
um by the end of 2023 and not touch it
and and have the discipline not to just
throw it in the markets but kind of
create that own game that own game
you're playing in the index fund World
play that somewhere else but you can
still have that motivation to still hit
these numbers in this goal because
that's that's a fun part of money too oh
yeah and Alex you're completely debt
free with an emergency fund
um I have a four thousand dollar card
debt that I'm paying my dad because he
sold it to me at zero percent interest
uh but that's it so four grand for a car
oh there's your new goal and
yeah pay that office yeah
for sure for sure especially since your
dad's holding the loan just get yeah
yeah that makes Thanksgiving awkward so
right do you enjoy money do you spend it
um I've had to flex that like learn to
flex that muscle the spending muscle
um but yeah I've given myself a hundred
dollars sometimes 150 every week for
whatever I want eating out
um going to the movies
um things like that just miscellaneous
spending what's your income
um 45 an hour I think uh is 93 000 a
year awesome that's another thing that's
pushing me into the saving cash
Direction I'm a contracted software
developer and they let me know my
contract will likely not be extended in
January so I know I'm losing my job in
January and I'm putting I'm doing some
things to fix that right I'm speaking
with the recruiter and my current boss
would happily give me a referral
but
um that also is partially why I call it
too because I really do need to save up
cash if I hypothetically can't get a job
the second I leave my current one yeah
for sure and I would I would try to have
something lined up thankfully you're in
a great uh career space though I mean
you're you're going to make great money
and there's a need for what you do so I
don't think you'll have a big issue
finding a job but that's exactly right
right so like all this kind of stuff
this life
um situations that you're in from the
debt to the job I mean let that yeah
that needs to be your motivator to be
like man I I gotta hit this dollar about
in order for me to feel good about that
transition out of my job and Rachel we
talk about this all the time on the show
there's only three things you can do
with money give save and spend yeah and
sometimes we can usually we're leaning
into the saving like Alex or we're
leaning into the spending and sometimes
when you release it through giving it
just changes your outlook on money and
if you're saving too much enjoy some of
it and do some something fun to remind
you that money is a tool and when we do
just one thing it kind of gives us a
blurry picture of what this money was
meant for that's a great Point George
yeah so even Alex I mean that generosity
piece too uh I think is a very very
important one so be giving something uh
practice building that muscle as well um
the saving one yeah like you got down
um but but be more focused intentionally
on what you're saving for and have a
purpose and a why behind the savings
which could help you not feel like
you're just like oh gosh playing this
Market kind of game yeah and joy can
come from all three things from saving
and give you some great peace and joy
from spending we can have joy and
incredible experiences and buying some
fun things but giving man there are some
wow that Joy surpasses both of those
combined and so just practice those
three things in moderation and I think
that will help give you a more healthy
relationship with your money but you're
doing great I mean this is a great spot
to be in a 24 making 90 3K and he's got
that savings muscle down and so we just
need to flex some of the other muscles
because I skipped leg day for what 33
years running now and this is what you
get you fit into skinny jeans people
when you Skip Leg Day for 33 years
George I'll get there Rachel once he's
gonna start working out with me right
that's right it looks like a Ken doll
of the Ramsay show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Rachel Cruz and all
the folks in the booth for keeping the
show flow into you America we thank you
so much for listening if you enjoyed
this episode share it with a friend
subscribe and let other people know
about this we love to impact more and
more people that puts this hour to the
ram to show in the books until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]